[Applause]
so and I also think and I think this is
laid out very thoroughly in the biblical
stories as well is that if there are
enough people who are admirable then
things work and if there aren't then
things things are terrible
you get wiped out you remember when
Abraham is bargaining with God with
regards to Sodom and Gomorrah he asks
God to save the city if there's like 40
admirable people right respectable but
let's say admirable right I don't want I
don't want to say good because good is
being corrupted in some sense by casual
usage
I mean admirable noble people right
I think Abraham bargains got down to
like 10 if there's 10 of them in the
city the city won't be destroyed
and that that's not very many in this
city so there's an interesting idea
there which is that there there doesn't
have to be that many people in a group
who have their act together but zero is
the wrong number and if it's zero then
then we're seriously in trouble and I
think that goes along with the idea of
the Pareto principle in economics -
which is that it's a small minority of
people who do most of the productive
work in any given domain but so so a
small number of of properly behaving
people might have enough of an impact to
keep everything moving and that might
also that might actually be true but it
can't fall below some crucial level and
I do think that we're in some danger of
allowing it to fall below some crucial
level because our society seems to be at
war in some ways against the idea of the
individual and individual character per
se and I think that's absolutely